tetris you finish first or not at all f
race 2000 I've been making films for
over 50 years women in cages the
sensational new motion picture that rips
the veil of the dirtiest racket ever
conceived by the minds of vicious men
directed 58 or 59 are not certain but I
know it's a fraction under 60 cheap tab
the whole town so she finds Harry attack
of the 50 foot cheerleader is maybe our
350 first or 350 second film it's our
first film in 3d he shot at a East Los
Angeles College with Jenna and Olivia
playing cheerleaders and they look
better than any cheerleaders I've ever
seen it starts as many films of this
type do with an experiment gone wrong so
the two of them become 50 feet tall and
the picture ends with the two of them in
a huge fight in a football stadium nude
from the waist up we believe a number of
people will want to see that see their
better looking than Godzilla even though
your tire still a little bit there's no
secret to making your film to me it's
fairly straightforward and I'm startled
about how many people don't follow it
for me it is pre production particularly
if you're treating on a low budget you
want to have everything
as well as you possibly can before shoot
it knowing that no picture ever goes
exactly how your planet but at least you
have a framework to deal with the most
difficult thing about making films is
not the actual shooting of the film as a
matter of fact the shooting of the film
today is easier than it was because the
equipment is better it's lighter it's
more portable it's easier to use the
most difficult thing is getting
distribution when I first started every
picture I made no matter how low the
budget we got a full theatrical
distribution today very few low-budget
pictures get theatrical distribution
commons tons that's goin in if i had one
thing to say to young filmmakers it
would be the persevere it is very
difficult and it's too easy to give up
you can't really want to be a filmmaker
you must stay there and do it anything
then whatever you want
cuz im an american sir and i love my
country
what Gore school be next